ja willkommen zur digitalen
ersatzsitzung der Vorlesung
Grundbegriffe der praktischen
Philosophie heute geht es um das Thema
Normativität konkreter um moralische
Normativität und ich möchte zunächst was
zum Wort Normativität sagen das ist gar
nicht so klar was das bedeutet
Normativität leitet sich ab vom
lateinischen Wort Norma und das bedeutet
ganz Verschiedenes wie zum Beispiel die
Richtschnur den Maßstab die Regel die
Vorschrift aber auch eine übertragenen
konkreten Sinne den rechten Winkel das
heißt man sieht Normen können in ganz
verschiedenen Bereichen und Hinsichten
gelten selbst wenn es um die Baukunst
geht und man sich da nach etwas
ausrichten muss Normativität in
bezeichnet also moralische politische
ästhetische man kann sie noch viele
weitere Dinge denken Geltung und
Verbindlichkeit gelten tun immer Regeln
Normativität ist die Geltung die in ganz
verschiedenen Bereichen Bedeutung hat
wir wollen uns jetzt vor allem in dieser
Vorlesung mit der moralischen
Normativität also dem moralischen
Geltung und Verbindlichkeit befassen das
heißt mit Normativität mit Regeln und
Vorschriften die unser Handeln betrifft
es geht ja hier um die Grundbegriffe der
praktischen Philosophie und nicht um
ästhetische Normen Richtlinien wonach
man schönes bildet darum geht es uns
nicht zu sehr in diese Vorlesung das
heißt die Normativität bezeichnet den
Bereich des Sollens desjenigen was zu
tun ist was wir tun sollen das sind
Gebote Verpflichtungen und auch
imperative bekommt darauf gleich noch
mehr zu sprechen jetzt stellen sich aber
einige Fragen genau genommen sogar drei
wie können wir Normativität begründen
dass das Begründungsproblem die zweite
Frage ist für wen gilt Normativität das
geltungsproblem das sind die zwei
wichtigsten Fragen aber es gibt noch
eine dritte Frage die mir auch noch
eingefallen ist nämlich wie können wir
Normativität erkennen das ist das
Erkenntnisproblem also es gibt genau
genommen drei Fragen das
Begründungsproblem von der nativität des
geltungsproblem und auch das
Erkenntnisproblem auf diese Fragen werde
ich jetzt näher eingehen ist nur auf die
Begründung moralische Normativität wir
konzentrieren uns jetzt hier vor allem
auf moralische Normativität also
moralische Normativität z.B moralische
Gebote diese Normativität die für unsere
Handeln gilt unser moralisches Handeln
die kann dadurch begründet werden dass
sie zum Beispiel Anspruch auf
Rationalität
Universalität und auf Autonomie erhebt
das werde ich jetzt ein bisschen genauer
erklären was damit gemeint ist wir
können also mit Bezug auf Vernunft
Vernünftigkeit oder Rationalität auf
universelle Bedeutung und auf den
Begriff der Autonomie der dadurch
besonders angesprochen ist versuchen
moralische Normativität zu begründen
könnte jetzt sagen das was vernünftig
ist sollte auch getan werden also
Normativität moralische Normativität
könnten wir über Vernunft versuchen zu
begründen wir können sagen es ist
vernünftig so und so zu handeln also
sollten wir so handeln wenn wir
voraussetzen dass Moral Unvernunft in
einem engen Zusammenhang miteinander
stehen das hat mir andere Philosophen
außerhalb von Kant wie zum Beispiel
David jung bestritten aber es ist eine
Möglichkeit moralische Normativität zu
begründen könnte auch anders versuchen
moralische Normativität zu begründen die
man sagt das was von universelle im
Interesse ist sollte auch getan werden
das sollte auch verbindlich gelten fast
die Interessen aller jetzt was Menschen
Personen Tiere Lebewesen das ist eine
andere Frage jedenfalls das was die
Interessen betrifft dass das von
Interesse ist das sollte auch getan
werden und zwar das universelle
Interesse nicht nur das Einzelinteresse
also das wäre der Versuch bei
Universalität moralische Normativität zu
begründen natürlich kann man das wieder
mit dem vernünftigen zusammenbringen und
sagen das was für universellem Interesse
ist das ist auch immer vernünftig und
deswegen ist es moralisch verbindlich
man könnte aber auch so argumentieren
dass man sagt das was unsere Autonomie
vergrößert also unsere Freiheit unsere
Selbstbestimmung vielleicht auch unsere
Selbstverwirklichung das sollte auch
getan werden und immer auch im Gegensatz
dazu das was unsere Autonomie
einschränkt das sollte verboten werden
das was nicht von universellen Interesse
ist was nur einzelne betrifft das sollte
kein moralisches Gebot sein oder mit
Blick auf den ersten Punkt der Vernunft
das was unvernünftig ist das was
irrational ist das sollte nicht getan
werden oder sollte vielleicht sogar
verboten werden man kann sich darüber
streiten ob das immer gleich das
unmoralische das Böse ist oder ob es
auch noch andere Bereich Technik gibt in
der Geschichte der Philosophie haben
wozu und kann versucht über
den Gedanken der Universalität und auch
der Autonomie
Normativität zu begründen und so hat den
Begriff des Gemeinwillen geprägt im
Gegensatz zum Willen aller der
gemeinwille drückt das gemeininteresse
aus und er ist eigentlich ein
vernünftiger Wille und genauso hat das
Immanuel Kant mit dem kategorischen
Imperativ gedacht dass der auch unsere
Vernunft ausdrückt unsere Autonomie
vergrößert und auch ein Ausdruck unserer
Vernunft ist
das ist noch mal die Formel des
kategorischen Imperativs handeln nur
nach derjenigen Maxime durch die du
zugleich wollen kannst dass sie ein
allgemeines Gesetz werden also hier
haben wir jetzt den Gedanken der
Universalität mit enthalten zugleich
aber haben wir den Gedanken der
Autonomie in diesem Satz ausgedrückt
weil ihr das allgemeine Gesetz auch
unser Gesetz ist dass wir uns geben und
den wir uns auch unterwerfen und
natürlich ist auch dieses Gesetz das
allgemeine nach kann zugleich ein
vernünftiges Gesetz es gibt noch eine
andere Formulierung des kategorischen
Imperativs handelt es so dass du die
Menschheit sowohl in deiner Person als
in der Person eines jeden anderen
jederzeit zugleich als Zweck niemals als
Mittel gebrauchst niemals bloß als
Mittel brauchst darin ist jetzt hier
der Gedanke der Autonomie angesprochen
moralische Normativität ist dasjenige
was unsere Autonomie vergrößert und was
verbietet dass wir nur als mit diesem
Zweck sprich gemäß der hypothetischen
imperative der instrumentellen Vernunft
gebraucht oder vielleicht sogar besser
instrumentalisiert werden das ist nicht
eine Form von moralischer Normativität
was Ausdruck allein instrumenteller
Vernunft ist da werden wir
instrumentalisiert da wird unsere
Autonomie nicht gewürdigt und unsere
würde auch nicht
jetzt gehen wir auf die geldtomoralische
Normativität ein der stellt sich die
Frage für wen gilt jetzt moralische
Normativität hier gibt es verschiedene
Möglichkeiten
auch wieder betrifft das die Frage was
wir eigentlich sind also gilt moralische
Normativität für alle Menschen für alle
vernünftigen und autonomen Personen oder
auch für nicht menschliche Tiere
das ist immer die Frage nach dem
Geltungsbereich wer ist Subjekt der
Normativität damit moralische
Normativität für ein Wesen gelten kann
muss es erstens diese erkennen können
und zweitens auch nach ihr Handeln
können das ist ganz wichtig sonst kann
einen Raum keine geldung für einen
bestimmtes Subjekt haben und die
normative geldung die scheint Freiheit
und Autonomie vorauszusetzen kleine
Kinder etwas sind noch nicht der
liegtsfähig also was die tun das kann
auch nicht moralischen Regeln oder auch
natürlich nach juristischen Gesetzen
geahndet werden weil man diesen Kindern
in einem bislang gewissen Alter noch
nicht die nötige Einsichtsfähigkeit
nötige Autonomie sprich Reife zusprechen
kann es gibt ein lateinischen Spruch der
hier auch wichtig ist ultra posse nemo
obligator Deutsch niemand wird über das
können hinaus verpflichtet oder anders
gesagt niemand soll oder darf über das
was er kann hinaus verpflichtet werden
es gibt eine andere kürzere Formel du
kannst denn du sollst also wenn wir
wirklich etwas sollen wenn das sollen
Objektiv ist dann können wir daraus
schließen das wird auch dem sollen Folge
leisten können spricht das wir auch das
prinzipiell zumindest tun können was wir
sollen können wenn wir etwas sollen was
wir nicht tun können dann macht das
sollen keinen Sinn dann hat die
Normativität eigentlich keine
Berechtigung
das kann normativ geboten sein was
prinzipiell in unserer Macht steht und
natürlich stets in unserer Macht nicht
unmoralisch zu handeln oder moralisch
gut sein und das können wir also macht
es in unserem Fall wenn wir ein gewisses
Alter erreicht haben durchaus Sinn das
für uns moralische Normativität gilt
jetzt kommen wir zu
erkenntnismoralischen Normativität wir
können wir moralisch Gebote erkennen
moralische Normativität wie zum Beispiel
moralische Gebote kann dadurch erkannt
werden dass man ihr Gegenteil als
vernünftig oder logisch widersprüchlich
erkennt also man geht von Gegenteil aus
und schließt dann aus der Falschheit des
Gegenteils auf die Wahrheit des Geburts
also das ist eine sogenannte Reduktion
hat absurd um eine widersprüchliche
einweis durch die Widersprüchlichkeit
des Gegenteils hier gibt es ein
konkretes Beispiel bei Manuel kann der
maximentest wir sind darauf auch schon
eingegangen kann das jetzt hier ein
konkretes Beispiel und zwar bringt er
jetzt eine unmoralische Maxime also ein
unmoralischen subjektiven
handlungsgrundsatz der lautet ich habe
es mir zu Maxime gemacht mein Vermögen
durch alles sichere Mittel zu vergrößern
kann möchte zeigen dass diese Maxime
unmoralisch ist dass sie kein Ausdruck
moralische Aktivität ist das wir diese
Maxime uns nicht zu eigen machen sollten
auch wenn wir sie uns natürlich zu eigen
machen können wer will freie Wesen sind
wie kann ich jetzt nach kann zeigen dass
diese Maxime mein Vermögen durch alle
sichere Mittel zu vergrößern unmoralisch
ist oder widersprüchlich ist er versucht
eben durch das Gegenteil also die zeigen
dass wenn ich sie mir zum maximal nach
diesen Grundsatz dass ich dann in einen
Widerspruch gerate es bringt ja ein
Beispiel jetzt ist ein Depositum ein
Depositum ist ein geliehenes gut in
meinen Händen dessen Eigentümer
verstorben ist und keine Handschrift
darüber zurückgelassen hat also nehmen
wir an ich leih mir einen Gegenstand und
die Person die mir den Gegenstand
geliehen hat die ist verstorben spricht
niemand weiß dass eigentlich dieser
verstorbenen Person dieser Gegenstand
gehört und jetzt das dann die Erben
diesen Gegenstand bekommen sollten also
dass ich diesen Gegenstand eigentlich
wieder zurückgeben müsste weil ich ihn
mir ja geliehen habe mit dem Versprechen
ihn irgendwann wieder zurückzugeben und
jetzt macht kann den konkreten
Anwendungsfall ich wende jene Maxime
also die Maxime mein Vermögen durch alle
sichere Mittel zu vergrößern auf den
gegenwärtigen Fall an dass die Person
die mir den Gegenstand geliehen hat dass
die Position verstorben ist und frage ob
sie diese Maxime wohl die Form eines
Gesetzes annehmen könnte mithin ich wohl
durch meine Maxime zugleich ein solches
Gesetz geben könnte dass jedermann eine
positive Abläufen dürfen
Niederlegung ihm niemand beweisen kann
also ob ich so tun kann als ob die
Gegenstand mir selbst gehört obwohl ich
mir nur geliehen habe und jetzt erkannt
wir können sofort die Falschheit die
Widersprüchlichkeit dieser Maxime
einsehen er sagt ich werde sofort gewahr
das ein solches Prinzip als Gesetz also
als universales Gesetz wenn es für alle
gelten sollten sich selbst vernichten
würde weil es machen würde das ist gar
kein sowieso schon gäbe also das ist
jetzt die Argumentation von Kant wenn
ich mir diese Maxime zu eigen machen
würde würde ich in einen Widerspruch
geraten man kann sich jetzt genauer
fragen was für ein Widerspruch das ist
also ein logischer Widerspruch und wie
ist es zu verstehen dass es kein
Depositum gebe darüber kann man sehr gut
weiter diskutieren ich würde es so
interpretieren dass dann der Unterschied
zwischen Besitz und Eigentum der für die
Rechtswissenschaft ganz zentrales dass
der dadurch aufgehoben wäre besitzen
kann ich vieles obwohl ich nicht
Eigentümer bin wenn ich mir etwas zum
Beispiel geliehen habe und diese
wichtige Unterscheidung die würde nach
Kant dann aufgehoben werden wenn wir
eine solche Maxime zu allgemein gesetzt
und machen könnte das heißt unser
vertrauenssystem wäre grundlegend
gestört und das können wir nach kann
nicht wollen und deswegen muss das
Gegenteil Geld und so versucht kann über
im Prinzip des Widerspruchs slogischen
Widerspruchs des willentlichen
Widerspruchs Verbindlichkeit im Sinne
der moralischen Normativität zu
begründen
ja das war jetzt ein kurzer Einblick in
die Bedeutung der moralischen
Normativität vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit